en tenue de combat ratière dans une main
coutelas dans l'autre eddy est prêt à
chasser les crabes
nous sommes sur son terrain de jeu
préféré à trois-rivières à sainte-luce
non loin de l'ancienne usine l'homme à
l'oeil averti et trouve rapidement un
trou intéressant ces pratiques parce que
déjà par rapport à la grandeur du trou
parce que en une fois prêché comme nous
faut compter ou à peu près quatre doigts
quatre doigts si le cadre est tout
content quand tu vois ça veut dire qu'au
delà des travaux conséquents ce qu'on
dit en citant certain nombre de
centimètres au niveau carapace a
beaucoup ils souhaiteront pitié à la
benne pour pas la peine on remet de son
trou donc madame en quatre parties
intimes au sol campbell ce serait quand
même bien comme bien me l'ont bien
d'ananas mais comment les plus beaux
tops comme ça a fini monter la voiture
est ensuite posé il faut attendre le
lendemain pour la relever
puis il dit va vérifier les matières qui
ont été posées hier soir wall un trou
savez du côlon mais moins d'arrogance
voit sa joie n'a donc plus le trou est
grand plus le crabe et groulx mais il
faut savoir la trappe et le tenir comme
la nième débouchés des faux-pas faut pas
venez violent l'un pour garder ma mère a
tout même les doux dingues et mes deux
mois chez les quads et au dodo quoi prix
des rays et khalid quand il ment et
pourquoi tirer gentiment quand un groupe
est stable ces cours est un méchant trip
aux tables vip et selon ses capacités
mais c'est dans le sac il dit a commencé
à chasser depuis le 15 février dernier
aujourd'hui il a environ 300 crabe qu'il
faut plonger pour les préparer à être
consommés on aurait bien aimé a ciblé
c'est un crabe j'étais donc un peu de
tout donc on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
mangent en fait quand il est dans la
nature pendant une année pour l'impôt ne
pas avoir de surprise ne pas avoir de
problèmes d'indigestion machine ça en le
plus pendant une semaine et je dirais
même pendant quinze jours avec des
feuilles sèches ça veut dire tout ce qui
est comme j'ai dit à l'instant enfin le
fruit à pain
feuille de banane sèche amas de cannes
etc
pendant quinze jours que ça que ça que
ça que ça vous allez voir quelque chose
à y trouver des world
ils vont lâcher leur esprit va comme ça
tout le temps mélissa et camille sont
partis des fidèles pillot dit il ya deux
euros cinquante les crabes
ils partent comme des petits pains je
connais dit je connais la qualité des
crabes qui va pêcher gc ou est-ce qu'il
va et tous et chaque année en fait si ce
round toujours avec de beaux crav bien
servi et ils sont bons aussi sont bien
juteux bien traités
rabat bien nourris bien traiter l'eau à
chaque caillou paniproblème pas quand on
l'attend cammalleri à la même aune aux
patrons pour mener le péché est petite
elle m'a appris
mais ici à part des problèmes pury pâte
à colombo et piment sans oublier les
morceaux de mangue ouvert et votre matou
tout sera fin prêt à être consommé pour
la pac